[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with a columnist at
the Daily Mirror Susie Boniface and
assistant comment editor at the Daily
Telegraph Madeline Grant they'll both be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
sunac allies call for Purge of Tory
Wright as truce ends the eye looks at
the mounting pressures on prime minister
Rishi sunak to sack Home Secretary
sowella bravaman
the times has the headline sunac will
deny King his trip to cop talks as
leader faces backlash over his decision
not to attend the event himself
sharma's call to tax excessive oil
profits the guardian looks at cop 26
president alok sharma's call to change
the windfall tax on oil and gas profits
you're not the Tory Messiah The Daily
Star leads with patients called to the
new prime minister to give nurses a pay
rise
pay up PM the mirror also leads on the
same topic
the telegraph leads with Rising fears of
University bias against fee paying
schools
mask closes deal for Twitter as big Tech
valuations loser billions that's the
headline on the front of the financial
times
and the express looks at the prospect of
an ambitious deal with the French to end
the migrant crisis
Navy probes submarine sex pest Scandal
so dailymail focuses on claims of
bullying and sexual harassment by women
in the submarine service
my baby's Brave fight inspired me to win
mine the sun looks at how Tyson Fury
nearly losing his daughter spurred him
on in the ring
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by columnist
at the Daily Mirror Susie Boniface and
assistant comment editor at the Daily
Telegraph Madeline Grant welcome to both
of you let's start with the front of the
eye and they're actually looking at uh
Rishi sunak and ministers
urging action over mental health care
Susie
yeah so this is just one of the first
obviously we all knew when Rishi took
over that he was going to be immediately
dealing with some very sticky situations
and one of the first ones is going to be
that uh he's facing calls to to sack
suela bravman who was then just
appointed to the role of Home Secretary
he's being worn that there's serious
cracks in in party unity and that there
needs to be a deal
um to sort that out within the party and
that because the Deep Cuts he and Jeremy
Hunter having to uh plan and impose
there's going to be huge problems on
with mental health uh national debt
British national debt we've seen as some
kind of junk bond and the only the only
way forward is going to be a new era of
austerity which is going to put NHS
spending uh really a long way down uh
the priority list and is going to cause
a huge number of problems so basically
the new prime minister has a lot of this
the last prime minister's problems to
deal with he's got huge a huge hole in
the finances he's got huge problems with
the NHS he's got huge problems within
his party can he fix it probably not
look I thought you might say yes he can
there
um Madeleine the issue with swella
bravaman I mean that's he's not going to
get rid of her is he
well I don't know I mean it remains to
be seen I mean from what we've heard so
far it seems like you know there are
serious question marks about her
conducts
um so it may well be that that he has to
um but I think the the headline of the
article is interesting because it kind
of implies that it might be uh the truth
is over and that there may be a kind of
broader Purge of the toy right within
the party which would be kind of you
know quite a fascinating thing I think
that right now Rishi sunak has inherited
as Susie said the intro from hell
um but actually a fair amount of
Goodwill in the conservative party
because I think there's a recognition
that you know he got some of the big
calls right over the summer that he he's
shown foresight and also that this is
last chance to learn stuff you know they
have to get behind sunac or or not or
they're doomed basically
um but one of the problems that Liz
truss got herself into was failing to
appoint ministers from a broad swave of
the party and given some of the dicey
calls that turn out will have to make
some potentially very unpopular things
we'll have to go through the House of
Commons
um any alienation of large ways of the
party would I think be a terrible
terrible misjudgment so um you know I
think this is just one of many um hot
button issues that it will be
fascinating to see what happens next and
Susie is that at the Times report what
about the Prime Minister deciding not to
attend cop 27 after the huge event that
was cop 26 and our commitment to it
exactly and this is another problem
which Ashley is going to cause him a lot
of issues uh both with voters and
popularity uh polls and also within his
own party
um so cop 26 was a big thing for the
tourists it was a big thing for Boris
Johnson and it's a big thing for a lot
of members of the party and now um
Richie sunac is sort of repeating Liz
truss's instruction to King Charles that
he should absolutely not attend despite
the fact that apparently Charles has
dead is chomping at the bit quote
unquote it says there to to get to uh I
think it's in Egypt isn't it and to
discuss and and to help uh convene talks
and and get governments to make
commitments about climate change and so
on which is an issue for voters in this
country is a big thing for conservative
voters for labor voters for everybody uh
the the polls are showing it is
something that is of growing interest
but uh the Prime Minister says look I've
got too much other stuff to do I can't
cope with melting ice caps as well
um and Charles on the loose somewhere so
he wants him constrained and at home
where he's not helped trying to sort of
you know Tire issues see like into some
commitments that are going to be
expensive or the things he won't be able
to make
um but this doesn't mean that the
problem's gone away you've still got
huge issues with uh green energy with
actually finding the money to invest in
the tech labor has just had at their
conference they've they've sold a big
policy which is the Great British Energy
company that would invest in Green
Technology and create new jobs the
conservatives don't have a reply to that
at the moment they this would have been
the perfect opportunity for Richardson
to go there and say right well here's
something that I can do right now I'm
already in government I don't need to
make this a policy I can just start
doing it but um he chose not to and he's
he's says he's staying at home to
concentrate on things and of course you
know no one's ever heard of prime
ministers working on the plane that just
never happened Madeline just on the the
um King the environment secretary is uh
saying that it's up to Charles whether
or not he attends the conference
um but in terms of the decision of the
Prime Minister Madeleine do you think
it's a mistake or is it a sufficient
excuse to say that the the woes with the
economy are just too many to to leave
the country to attend cop 27.
well I think that if the king wanted to
go then that's his decision personally I
think that I I I think I think that
that's an issue that Charles is very
much committed to and has been leading
the way I think I disagree with Susie
and that I I think actually it is quite
legitimate for the Prime Minister not to
attend cop I mean Britain is very much
leading the world in so many of these
areas I don't think that we need to
prove that prove our worth in this
regard I think actually we've made much
greater commitments than many comparable
Western Nations and actually I think
people would understand given the level
of the cost of living crisis and a
number of fighting uh fighting fires on
many different fronts why on this
occasion especially since this cop is
not quite as consequential as the one in
Glasgow last year
um why you know giving it a Miss on this
occasion would be would be acceptable
and it's it's not the first time that a
prime minister hasn't attended and
instead has sent ministers and other
deputies along I don't I don't think
it's that controversial for myself Susie
to the uh mirror and the Prime Minister
very very quickly tell us about his um
interaction with a member of the public
perhaps didn't go quite as he thought it
might
nope so uh we should do one of these
things with the prime ministers you know
they put their they tuck their tie into
their shirt buttons and they wander
around a very clean Hospital world where
everyone's been asked if they'd like to
talk to the Prime Minister and they say
yes please and he came up to a lady
called Catherine Poole who's 77 at this
hospital in South London he was visiting
and he asked her you know the kind of
anodyne question you just asked someone
in the hospital when you really don't
care about the other are they looking
after you all right Deary is everything
okay and she gave him an absolute
talking to about how the nurses weren't
paid enough he said well I am trying and
she said well you need to try better
it's not good enough they're they're
doing a fantastic job and you need to
put your finger out and the trouble is
that regardless of the fact that um you
know Richie sunac can say well I'd like
to pay them more but I can't do this
under Rishi as Chancellor all the recent
budget increases for the NHS pay Rises
have had to come out of the nhs's
existing budget they didn't pay them any
extra so every time that the the Tory
government under Rishi pronounced that
there was going to be a pay rise for
doctors and nurses that was money that
came out of existing Hospital budgets
that you did say to Catherine and Paul
that he would take into consideration
what she had said so he listened to do
it though doesn't it Susie and Madding
thanks very much for the moment I'm
gonna take a break coming up much more
including this story on the front of the
financial times their headline must
close this deal for Twitter as big Tech
valuations lose billions to stay with us
for much more
[Music]
[Music]
Blockbusters are back on Sky Cinema
let's do this here we go you should go
so when do we start
[Music]
jungles eat people like us let's go
let's light this candle
that's right Blockbusters are back let's
have some fun
enjoy the latest Blockbusters only on
Sky Cinema
Sky Sports presents three thrilling live
games with a big chance
this is
that is unbelievable
and on Sunday West Ham traveled to Old
Trafford that is what he is all about
don't miss the action it's only live
once the Premier League continues to add
Sky Sports go to sky.com Sports
have a spooky Halloween get two of these
tubs of sweets for six pounds and these
cadburys treats for just 125. more ways
to save with Morrisons
[Music]
excuse me
let's evolute your way into currency
exchange download revolut now
let's do Knockouts
[Music]
I'm that girl I'm that boss enjoy every
meal with hello fresh home cooking Made
Easy and affordable order now at
hellofresh.co.uk I sentence you to six
days of blocked nose
your honor I have vix Sinex and plea for
the verdict to be shortened by two days
vix Sinex no other nasal spray is proven
to unblock the nose faster while helping
you recover up to two days earlier
vix Sinex
forget doing the daily clean of your
hands and knees The Flash speed mops two
times thicker and wet across that's all
those sticky bits and curvy bits so you
can stand up to daily dirt and to defeat
daily dust and pet hair pop on the new
speed mop dry pan and lock Dustin here
in a single swipe without having to
shift your sofa daily dust and hair is
done for with new Fresh Feed mob dry
pads
oh oh these people overpaid for their
International money transfers oh switch
to ofx and get 24 7 access to a currency
specialist you'll get Bank beating rates
and round-the-clock phone access to our
of experts helping you make transfers at
the right time and right rate which
could save you thousands or you can
simply use ofx online it could be the
difference between a profit or a loss
real people here to help
[Music]
[Music]
two live happy at all protected
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Commerce at the
Daily Mirror Susie Boniface and
assistant comment editor at the Daily
Telegraph Madeline Grant welcome back to
both of you let's have a look at this uh
Twitter story and uh Elon Musk
acquisition who's 44 billion pound
takeover uh it wasn't a straightforward
acquisition but he has got the goods
nonetheless um at the end of it all
Madeleine Madeleine
yes yes he does um but it seems to be
causing a certain amount of financial
term well in the world of big Tech
um it seems I mean I wasn't really aware
of this until I read this piece but it
seems like it's come around at the worst
possible time for Silicon Valley
generally as it coincides with
um you know the the ongoing economic
problems but also a massive slowdown in
the digital advertising that pays for
social media and I think it's as banks
have scrabbled around to lend the money
to Twitter it's made lending to other
platforms more difficult just at the
time when their valuations are also
taking a ham ring so Facebook has tanked
recently because Mark Zuckerberg's
metaverse has um has not been a success
to put it mildly despite the billion
sunk into it so it seems like Jester's
Elon musk's takeover of Twitter is
causing a fair amount of uh excitement
and turmoil online
um a similar thing is happening
financially and it's exposing the fact
that many big Tech firms haven't been
particularly good at reining in their
costs and the speculation Susie is as to
whether he will allow a small president
of the United States Donald Trump back
on Twitter
yeah now Madeleine's right to say that
um you know this is elon's bought at the
top of the market it's a bit Bonkers and
most of it seems been bought with debt
which is also quite Bonkers but you know
there used to be a question that every
doctor would ask if you hit your head or
you have some kind of psychotic break a
doctor would ask you if you knew who the
Prime Minister was now recent events
have made that a bit of a waste of time
so I think it would be a very good idea
to replace that question perhaps with
the suggestion that as it says here in
the Ft Donald Trump says that Twitter's
now in a sane Pair of Hands now if a
doctor said to somebody does Donald
Trump think you're sane then that would
be an excellent way of qualifying
someone I think to be immediately
sectioned or given some kind of
diagnosis Susie we must leave it there
thank you very much for your analysis
and uh Madeline also we'll see you in
the next hour and there will be